Điều đàn đà bán hành lấy hạn chế tại khu vực không phải aił gian Homos,
gió của tập trận bán đặc thật của côn đổi trong khu vực.
Lấy nha chế được đưa ra khi mà các khí tải quân sự của Mỹ đã đến chung lâm,
phản à đến sự ra tăng căn thẳng trong khu vực.
Theo thông báo của Yirang,
cuộc tập trận côn sự giễn ra từng emy vệ đến 2 chi tế một gần aił gian Homos.
Khu vận tại khu vực này được sẽ vào giễn hạn chế,
đáng huy giận với các chuyến vài giống mật độ hành động côn sự tà cao.
Nó dù đây là thủ tục kêu chuẩn, đối với các cuộc tập trận,
nhưng thông báo được đưa ra trong đối cạnh của Nè dưới Rán và Mỹ đàn căn thẳng.
Lâm dưới lên lo ngại về huy cơ liêu thang tại khu vực.
Tào sân vài U.S.A.Pra Hamlin-Cô và Một số tàu hộ tổng của Mỹ đã đi vào khu vực chung đồng.
Tổng thống trong tiên đối, khiến đàn có một thạm đổi hùng hộ khác,
tụng đàn tiến tạo khu vực này.